[Applaudissements]
et en tête je vais donner je vous
demander de venir tous les deux ça va
mon chéri dalle super tu trouve beau
est-ce que je me trouve beau si jamais
je sais ce que tu trouves beau basket
c'est pourquoi je te pose cette question
parce qu'on va faire un petit jeu dans
un instant on va tester notre notre
beauté une société a créé une
application qui nous permet de savoir si
on met bout à bout pas et elle donne une
note sur sainte émilie rattache au ski
voilà elle a regardé la caf à 4,5 sur 5
les délais de ces motards ont sans doute
inquiète mais non on a rentré parce
qu'on voulait patrie chine
on a rentré les visages dans
l'application 1a le classement de la 11e
à la personne numéro facile hein c'est
une application ça ne veut rien dire me
fait de la peine pour la personne en
dernière position et c'est pas du tout
méritée officines je pense qu'ils ont
marqué
c'est pas nous c'est la numéro 10
gilles séchage 2003 n est pas maintenant
il est malin il est magnifique
je suis très contente tout ça c'est le
très bonne note ah oui je te raconte en
neuvième position
c'est jean-michel pays il n'est pas
facile et beaucoup
non
celui qui est le huitième plus beau
gainey et bien c'est moi julien courbet
cercle avec 2,6 j'avais dix septième
position sur y est il son stress directs
jouent leur bonheur
[Applaudissements]
photo ll ne vous met pas dans les
meilleures franchement est ce la
première fois de ma vie j'ai la moyenne
sixième position maxime gagnon
[Applaudissements]
la photo est très bien doté tout sur
cette photo comme on est très premier
degré
non mais je crois que vous êtes en train
de piquer je suis en cinquième position
avec 2,9 en mai l'arrivée retient les
garçons 4e position et là je vous le dis
on fait un bon niveau des notes
ah ouais enfin bon au niveau des notes
en quatrième position c'est géraldine a
très bien avec 3,6
[Applaudissements]
en troisième position
ça m'a botté par don cheadle rythme à
merveille
t'es pas sérieux bétail le grand gagnant
nous c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin
[Musique]